well the reality is that when you manage
your time more effectively you actually
create more freedom and the challenges
that procrastination is so universally
accepted it's like fear and stress
become so stressed out and it's become
such our norm that it's okay I like to
set quarterly goals instead of annual
goals I like to make them a bit more
bite-sized wanna soar get a mentor
[Music]
hey it's Evan Carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you you've
got Michael Jordan level talent add
something so today let's learn from one
of the best Lisa Nichols and how to be
more productive and achieve more in life
mentor me Lisa
okay let's pick it off with rule number
one master time management so when you
look at prioritizing it really lives in
and I must say this word and you're
probably not going to hear it but when I
tell you it's a game changer
when you master and just for now begin
to operate inside of time management I
use some resist time management because
I'm like I'm a free spirit / people will
call me a rebel back in the day meaning
I didn't want to be controlled I want it
I'm a butterfly I wanted to I wanted to
soar I wanted to be free or the reality
is that when you manage your time more
effectively you actually create more
freedom that was a huge shock to me
somebody's gonna be lil right now like
break through out loud because when you
time manage meaning I'm gonna use better
blocks of my time let me give you some
examples for that let me use better
blocks of my time meaning I'm only gonna
go on my email three times a day I go on
my email about 9:30 between 9:20 and
9:40 I go on my email I stay in my email
for 30 minutes I'll go back in my email
about 3 o'clock in the afternoon I stay
in my email again for about 30 minutes I
go back a name or one more time at 6
p.m. I stay in for about 30 minutes
that's it I don't go in 19 times I don't
go in 20 times because 3 times a day
gives me adequate time to see
in there see what's new and act
appropriately otherwise it's throwing me
off I'm blocked my day about 90 minutes
each time blocked to do a task even if a
task only takes me 30 minutes I timed
like 90 minutes because I get distracted
but when you time block your your day
and then you schedule each day not every
day looks the same I have a time block
for everything I need to do for seven
days out of the week can you believe
that in that time I got more things done
you have to become comfortable with your
note my grandmother says baby
she starts every sentence with baby baby
if you want your yes to have more value
you need to learn how to exercise your
note see your yes might not have this
value anymore why because you give it
away too much you give it to too many
people you give it away too often you're
always over committing and then you feel
drained and frustrated and you don't
have gratitude in your heart because
you're over committed well that all
started with a yes that should have been
enough or should have been a I'd love to
but not now and so number two number one
is more effective time management that
has your agenda in it it has your
priority priorities in it right now your
agenda is covered with everyone else's
task I often I heard once if you don't
have your agenda then you're gonna work
for somebody else's agenda and so number
one is your time measure with your
agenda and number two is operating
utilizing and being comfortable and a
note and not an attitude no not to like
of thanks no like no not that mmm-hmm
just a no not now no I I would love to
but my plate is full I'm free in 90 days
just don't make no no energy just not
don't be surprised when everyone comes
to you you're great you're amazing
you're brilliant look at you you're on
this channel so you know you smart you
want a better life you want a an
abundant life of course you're here of
course I want you and your priorities
matters rule number two recognize the
cost of your actions so many times
people look at the habits that they have
such as procrastination and asked why do
i procrastinate
well I pose that question back to you
ask yourself what's the benefit because
there's a benefit that you're getting
out of it so whether you believe that
last-minute throws you inside of an
energy source because that's what I used
to think I spent all last minute I'm
more creative well the truth is you're
not more creative last minute the truth
is that when you wait to the last minute
you're increasing your stress level
you're bringing down your joy you're
eliminating peace of mind when you
understand the cost procrastination is a
word and the challenge is that
procrastination is so universally
accepted
it's like fear and stress become so
stressed out and it's become such our
norm that it's okay well ask yourself
the question what's the price that I pay
because I believe any behavior that you
don't want any longer the way that the
catalysts of change is recognizing the
price because we're high producers we
can still get it done inside of
procrastinating we can still get it done
but if you ever take a moment to stop
and ask yourself and answer what's the
cost of me procrastinating and you can
do that for everything but we're focused
on procrastination now what's the cost
of me procrastinating let's go down that
list when you procrastinate it costs you
clear organizational time because now
you're rushing when you procrastinate it
cost you peace of mind when you
procrastinate you're now throwing in
urgency urgency increases your stress
urgency is known to increase your stress
if you live in urgency you literally are
two three times more likely to have a
heart attack
I hear not confirm but that's what I
hurt so if you live in this pace of
urgency all the time because of a
behavior that you can modify think about
it how are we for moving a bully mobile
how are we brilliant and operating in
something we can control
there's so many things that you can't
control procrastination is something
that you can go drop also if you want to
learn to have more confidence check out
my 254 series they're free the link to
join are in the description below
you're gonna play ginormous a ginormous
but first take baby steps we validate
who we are by what we're doing for other
people so many times I get the question
how do I prevent failure and I'd love
for you to spend that same energy going
how could I ensure that I soar rule
number 3 set quarterly goals I like to
set quarterly goals instead of annual
goals I like to make them a bit more
bite-sized now i start with a big
bodacious scary hairy goal right then I
immediately release that goal and chunk
it down into four smaller goals that are
bite-sized digestible and palatable I
can measure them every 90 days you want
to be able to measure write this down
you want to be able to measure your
actions your goals and your milestones
every 90 days when you do that it allows
you to see how close on path you are
have you exceeded your own expectation
if you have a goal that this year I want
to make an additional forty five
thousand dollars all I make an
additional hundred thousand dollars and
you get to the first quarter and you're
thirty thousand dollars in you know
you're on path however if you have the
goal over the year I want to make an
additional hundred thousand dollars and
you get to the end of the first quarter
and you're at ten thousand dollars in
additional revenue you know you need to
do something you know you need to ramp
up or you know that this next season
this next time I need to make sure that
I'm doubling up on my revenue to hit
that goal versus getting to November and
realizing that you're only at thirty
five thousand dollars towards your
hundred thousand dollar additional
revenue goal whatever your goal is
whether it's a hundred thousand or where
there's ten thousand or where there's a
million dollars in addition or whether
it's new relationships or whether it's a
social media rule number four live in
alignment of your purpose I love the
phrase willpower but willpower isn't
something you conjure up willpower isn't
something you drink willpower isn't
something you download from Google what
you're talking about is how do I make
the choices that are in alignment with
my highest purpose and my highest vision
for myself that's what you really want
to ask see your life is a physical
manifestation of the choices that you
made up into this moment I'm gonna say
that again because that gets a little
deep and that can go over some people's
head that can hit you sometimes right
between the eyes and you got to hear the
second time so here goes your life right
now as it exists today your finances
your weight your relationships your
career your self-esteem your self-image
your spiritual awareness all of that is
a result of the choices that you've made
up into this moment big and small and
just so you know your life the way it
appears today is not a result of a few
big choices even though that's the thing
that we look back on we go up I
shouldn't have moved out of the state oh
I shouldn't have got into that
relationship up I shouldn't have we look
at the big things well I'm here to
disrupt that mindset a bit your life
experience right now is not so much a
result of your big choices why those
impact you it's really a result of a
bunch of small little choices made
consistently over a long period of time
because those are the habits and the
behaviors that you've gotten into so we
can talk about willpower and how do I
build willpower as if it's something
that you can flex in the gym or
something you can do crunches or abs or
triceps and build but it's not the
question you should ask the answer you
should be seeking is what does it take
to make my choices become a
with the life that I say I want to live
now when you say choices it makes it
really sobering because even when you
choose to sit down on yourself it was a
choice so I ask you in this moment what
will it take you to decide to make the
choice today don't even think about
tomorrow don't think about next week but
to make the choice today that's in
alignment with your health goals make a
choice today that's in alignment with
your financial goals it's the small
things it's the extra visit to Starbucks
it's the extra biscuit it's the giving
up early it's ten more crunches it's
doing squats every time you go to the
bathroom at least that's what I do I do
ten I do ten every time I go to the
restroom I'm already there I'm just
gonna keep on going just because I want
to stand alignment with my goal and my
goal is to have a body that at least
creates a double-take or or triple date
maybe I don't know I wanted to create a
body that is in alignment with my goal I
want to be able to go paintballing with
my nephews and my son the way I just did
recently I want to be able to go jet
skiing so when I look at my life in my
lifestyle that I want to maintain it
requires me to hike a little longer it
requires me to eat more vegetables and
protein it requires me my choice of how
I want to live requires my alignment and
what I put in my body or how I stay
active in my body so when I date I don't
I don't do dinner dates I'm not
interested in doing dinner dates you
want to date me let's go on a hike let's
go skating ice skating roller skating is
going to walk
I want active dates in my dating
experience because that's an alignment
with my life's purpose so what are you
choosing let's not even look at
willpower
let's look at choices because choice is
something you can control in every
single moment and the choice you made
yesterday if it wasn't alignment with
your greatest goal and your highest
purpose
okay yesterday's yesterday make a new
choice today you're not ever condemned
or sentenced to making the same choice
over and over and over again every day
every moment you have a new opportunity
to make a new choice I'm rule number
five the last one before a very special
bonus clip is create micro wins this
whole piece of my book abundance now I
wrote it a while ago and it's amazing in
terms of just talking about and breaking
down what's the difference between a
macro win and a micro wind and a micro
win is that smaller goal that's you can
see it's attainable you get that instant
result and most people are chasing the
macro win all the time and they're not
looking at all the micro wins that they
can feel really good about to get them
to that macro zone if you create 5 7 8
10 micro lens guess what now you're in a
rhythm now you're building some
consistency now you like the way it
feels and then before you know it you
look up and go whoa there's that macro
win that huge goal that I thought was a
hundred miles away it wasn't a hundred
miles away it was seven eight eleven
micro wins
now I have a special bonus clip from
Lisa on how to disrupt your soil that I
think you're gonna enjoy now before that
is that where the three-point landing
questions let's go from just watching a
video to taking action here we go
question number one what is a micro wind
that you can create today number two
what are three goals that you want to
accomplish within the next quarter and
number three where are you living out of
alignment with your purpose and if you
liked this video and promised to take
action after watching it give me a hash
tag believe down in the comments below
there's so much value in what you
unlearn sometimes the best thing you can
do is unlearn some things we're all
always going after learning something
new because we're information junkies
because we have all these forms of
information coming at us on the internet
coming at us in books coming at us on
the radio coming at us in television
that we want to learn learn learn but
sometimes your biggest breakthrough is
in what you unlearn and then you relearn
sometimes you have to disrupt your soil
pull your soil up take that dry dirt
that's been planted for years I know
I've just been knowing this for years
it's what my mother taught me that's
what we've always done
you have to disrupt that soil in order
to plant a new seed to grow a new fruit
yeah yeah you guys got that and so I
came very comfortably to disrupt your
soil like that's what I came for to
disrupt your soil not to necessarily
keep you comfortable what you know stay
comfortable that I want to disrupt you
with some things that are new awareness
to go oh wait hold on or new awareness
about what you've been doing based on
what you've known forever that doesn't
fit your future anymore because I can
guarantee you every single one of us who
want something different than what we're
getting we're doing something
unconsciously from all patterns that
doesn't even serve our future that's
when the tongue in your mouth and the
tongue in your shoe are going in two
totally different directions and your
job is to align them up so that you can
move forward in a powerful way
if you want my take on Lisa's five best
pieces of advice check out the video
right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there and I wanted to get to the
top and there's no elevator to the top
people often want want to call me the
exception like oh my god you're the
exception No